[Music]
are we alone in the universe with more
than 100 billion galaxies in the
observable universe and at least 500
billion planets in the Milky Way alone
don't you think we should have found
something by now even if a tiny
percentage of those billions of planets
hosted intelligent life there would be
tens of thousands of extraterrestrial
civilizations out there yet we haven't
seen any where is everybody
we keep wondering what's taking them so
long to come but what if I told you that
even the friendliest of all aliens could
wipe out our entire civilization for
good this is what if and here's what
would happen if aliens visited us
tomorrow
[Music]
we tend to apply our theories to the
rest of the universe we expect aliens to
come for a visit even though we
ourselves haven't traveled out of our
own neighborhood yet
we just believe that they've had so much
more time for technological progress to
make space travel possible so here they
are with their shiny alien spaceship
roving above our heads what would we do
as far as we know no government on this
planet has any sort of alien greeting
party planned if aliens suddenly showed
up on the horizon just try to keep cool
say the aliens happen to be very polite
and sent us a signal before invading our
planets personal space well you wouldn't
know it right away
not until several observatories
maintained by different organizations
verified that signal yep that's it
aliens are here now you know you got
this shocking news from your TV NASA
officially confirmed an alien ship
detected in the solar system not alone
in the university agencies and countries
around the world would be working
together quickly trying to assess the
level of threat
they'd summon experts in linguistics
psychology combat and biology and have
them attempt to make first contact with
the aliens
groups of experts would record all
interactions to analyze simple alien
gestures and auditory reactions those
would help to decide whether aliens came
in peace or they intend to do some
serious damage
some people might believe that religious
leaders to do all the talking
something's telling me that aliens
didn't learn our languages in school so
good luck to anyone trying to reach out
to them while the world's most
intelligent people were busy trying to
interpret the aliens intentions to the
best of their ability
you would be wait are you curious to
know what the aliens look like some
evolution experts agree that things like
proteins and DNA are the same no matter
where in the universe you're from if
that's true alien evolution would be
close to that of humans
they'd have binocular vision with eyes
located close to the brain just like us
they'd be based on land and have a
minimum of two legs for mobility and
three fingers so that they could handle
tools still if some of our own
life-forms look like this try to picture
something coming from another planet
meanwhile on earth while governments
were busy figuring out the action plan
the media would be keeping you informed
you'd be advised to stay indoors and
wait for further instructions it'd be
hard to filter out what's legitimate
news and what isn't but try not to fall
for fake into the world news on Facebook
and keep calm at least make an effort to
give up the urge to pack up your
belongings and head for the hills at the
same time the government's and
scientific experts would be sharing
information about alien interactions
from here the events could unfold in a
few different ways first we may not get
any auditory or visual response nothing
at all this could mean anything from the
alien spacecraft doesn't have any aliens
on board - the aliens are waiting for
their alien backup to fry us up
another possibility is that aliens
responded and tried to communicate with
no weapons involved I can't speak to
their possible intentions for all we
know they may want to get rid of us and
keep the earth to themselves thanks to
the language barrier our interactions
might not be going well tensions would
begin to rise we'd be screwed
[Music]
considering that these beings have the
technology to travel to earth it's
likely that they also had the capability
to develop some very very advanced
weaponry civilians would most likely be
hitting the panic button as hard as
possible meanwhile government's would
put their nuclear weapons on standby
that will be our best and most
destructive weapon against them or so we
think it may turn out that the aliens
have adverse reactions to things on
earth that we are all accustomed to if
say their skin melted upon contact with
water then defending ourselves against
them would be simple
I'm not saying aliens would necessarily
bring doom upon the earth they may not
mean us any harm at all but if some
hazardous microorganisms from outer
space hitched a ride with them and made
it into our world we humans might have
no natural immunity to those
extraterrestrial microbes and they could
slowly wipe our species off the planet
on the other hand if aliens weren't
coming here to make friends
we'd be destroyed long before we got a
chance to offer peace between
intelligent beings
in any case we aren't ready for a visit
from interplanetary travelers
we'd better get prepared for first
contact or maybe we should try to invade
alien worlds before they invade us but
that's a topic for another what-if
[Music]
you
[Music]